I want to tell you a quick story about when Uncle Jake was a kid and when uncle
Jake learned some things that were very important to him and
that really helped him begin to lead a better life.
So there's a lesson to this story.
It's like a fable.
And so pay attention and see if you can learn what the lesson is.
So here's the story from Uncle Jake.
When I was a little kid,
I was running in a race.
It was a pretty long race for kids.
My Dad had taken me to another town to run the race because I liked running.
The race was about four miles long.
Adults and kids were both running at the same time,
so it was kind of crowded and it was hard to even see with all the people around
it was the biggest race I had ever been in.
As soon as it started,
I ran really hard,
as hard as I could,
and it seemed like I was winning the race,
at least it seemed like I was winning for all the kids that were in the race.
Yeah.
But I didn't look back.
I kept looking ahead and focused on winning.
I didn't look back at all because I knew that looking back slows you down.
I just ran and ran and ran and I was really,
really tired.
But I kept running as hard as I could
even when I felt tired,
I kept pushing.
And finally I got towards the end of the race and I started to recognize where
the finish line was going to be and I turned the last corner
okay.
And saw the finish line in Ireland headed for it.
And once I turned the corner and I started getting closer to the finish line,
the crowd started to cheer.
They started to cheer loud.
They must be cheering from me.
I thought,
I must be winning.
I am going to win this race.
I will be the champion.
I thought to myself,
as I picked up my pace,
the closer I got to the finish line,
the louder everyone got.
They were screaming and cheering and I was running so hard,
I was looking straight ahead,
just bounding towards the finish line.
Then they were screaming and it was like I was famous.
And finally I sprinted across that finish line and I was so proud of what I had
done.
Can I slow down?
And then I came to a stop and then I looked up to see all of my adoring fans,
but they weren't looking at me.
Okay.
They were looking at someone else
and they kept cheering and now they were cheering even louder and I could
suddenly tell that they hadn't been cheering for me at all.
And I looked behind me to see what they were cheering at
and then I saw what they were cheering at.
Yeah.
I saw a father who was pushing his daughter in a wheelchair
and she must've had a very bad disease because she couldn't really even hold her
head up.
But as our dad pushed her and the crowd cheered loud,
she did her best to wave to the crowd and she smiled and waved at her.
Dad pushed her across the finish line.
He looked very tired.
Okay.
And she looked very happy.
And I,
I felt embarrassed.
I felt embarrassed because I'd been so proud of myself thinking I had done such
a great thing.
Not knowing that there was someone right behind me that was doing something even
better,
something even harder,
something that took more courage than what I had done.
And I went over to the girl and her father and I smiled and I said,
nice job on the race.
And her mouth moved and it looked like she was trying to say thank you because I
don't think she could talk,
but the dad said,
thank you young man,
you ran a good race too.
Thanks sir.
I said,
yeah.
Then he pushed her away to get some water
and I realized two very important lessons.
Okay.
The first one is that even when I'm doing something very challenging,
there's always someone that is doing something even more challenging.
Okay.
And more important than that,
I realized that the world doesn't revolve around me.
I thought everyone was cheering from me and that made me feel good.
I thought I was the center of the world.
Okay.
But that is seldom the case.
There's a big world out there and I'm only part of it.
Okay.
And I needed to stay humble and think about other people.
And not only of myself.